On arrive, oui. Bien.
Tu viens à sa soirée après?
Il y a des chances. Et toi?
Faut voir... Tu sais à quelle
heure ça finit?
Non, pas du tout.
On y est.
Ravis de vous rencontrer,
Monsieur Darin!
On a une interview avec
l'agence de presse demain.
- Demain? Tu rigoles?
- Je sais bien. Ce sera pas long!
C'est ma soirée avec la famille! Tu
sais que c'est important pour nous!
- Je peux avoir un autographe?
- Voilà. Bonne soirée!
Je ne te demande pas plus que deux
minutes!
C'est le seul soir où je ne veux
pas avoir à faire ce genre de truc!
On fête mon anniversaire de
mariage, je te rappelle!
C'est important! Ils t'ont raté en
Floride, on ne peut plus les éviter!
Bonne chance, Bobby!
Je te le rappellerai demain matin.
Salut Bobby! Bonne soirée!
-Salut Charlie!
-Donne-moi tes lunettes. Parfait.
Et maintenant Mesdames et Messieurs,
ce soir, pour son dixième
anniversaire dans le show business,
le Coconut Grove
est fier d'accueillir le seul,
l'unique Bobby Darin!
Merci! Trois suppositions. Faux!
Stop! Stop! Richie! Stop! Stop!
Arrêtez! Arrêtez!
Ok, on reprend du début, je veux la
refaire
Allons, tu plaisantes!
C'était parfait!
Non, je veux recommencer,
je peux faire mieux.
Tu te rends compte du temps qu'il
faudra pour tout remettre en place?
Je ne sais pas si mes lèvres vont
encore pouvoir tenir longtemps!
Quand tu joueras correctement,
on s'arrêtera,
mais si tu continues à saloper le
boulot
comme tu l'as fait toute
cette après-midi,
on recommencera encore et encore
jusqu'à ce que ce soit parfait!
Mais, Bobby, les gars sont crevés,
c'est tout!
Et moi, alors!
Allez, préviens tout le monde.
Mesdames et Messieurs, vous pourrez
partir dans quelques minutes, mais..
Attendez!
S'il vous plaît, restez assis
jusqu'au départ de M. Darin, merci.
La sonnerie s'il vous plaît!
Bobby! On ne peut pas recommencer
cette prise, comme ça, sans arrêt!
Ecoute, si Bobby dit qu'il peut
faire mieux c'est que c'est vrai!
- Mais il agresse tout le monde!
- Laisse-le se détendre un peu.
Monsieur Darin, vous voulez tout
reprendre du début?
Bobby, tu sais que la presse
est là, aujourd'hui.
Accorde leur une minute, tu veux!
On reprend dans dix minutes!
Que personne ne s'éloigne!
-Comment tu te sens?
-J'en sais rien, Charlie.
Allez, te fais pas de bile!
Viens. Il faut y retourner.
Assemble ces deux morceaux,
je regarderai ça après le dîner.
Monsieur Darin! David a dit que
je peux vous parler aujourd'hui.
-On peut faire ça maintenant?
-Il est occupé, là!
M. Darin, personne n'a encore jamais
fait un film sur sa propre vie.
Bien sûr que ça a déjà été fait!
C'est un autoportrait, mais en film!
Vous pensez vraiment pouvoir être
objectif sur votre propre vie?
Ecoutez! Quand il était petit, on
lui a appris à ne jamais mentir,
-Et c'est ce qu'il fait!
-Excusez-moi, mais... qui êtes-vous?
Son beau-frère! Et si vous le
cherchez, vous aurez affaire à moi!
Je ne cherche personne, Monsieur!
Mais honnêtement, admettez-le!
Il est trop vieux pour ce rôle!
Il est né pour interpréter ce rôle
et vous le savez très bien!
Fichez le camp d'ici!
-Merci Charlie!
-Quelle connerie!
Tu serais trop âgé pour jouer ton
propre rôle?! Allez, viens, on y va.
Ok tout le monde!
On change le début.
-Quoi? Et pourquoi, Bobby?
-Commencer par Mackie, c'est risqué!
Au contraire, commencer par
celle-là, c'est courageux!
Le message c'est: vous voulez voir
ce dont je suis capable? Me voilà!
Non! C'est une erreur!
Et si on faisait "Hello, young
lovers"?
Commence donc avec le début de ta
maladie!
Nina, c'est son histoire, laisse-lui
le temps d'y réfléchir!
Non! N'essaie pas de me faire taire,
je sais ce qui est important, moi!
Tout a commencé quand il est tombé
malade.
Nina arrête, s'il te plaît!
On devrait commencer par la fois où
je me suis fait huer sur scène.
Enfin! Personne ne viendra te voir
te faire huer et sortir de scène!
Restes-en à tes succès!
C'est ça qui qui se vend!
Comment tu sais ce que les gens
viendront voir, Boum-Boum?
Depuis quand es-tu expert?
Bien vu, Bobby!
-Nina!
Dis donc! Je te connais depuis
toujours, alors pour tes affaires,
je suis l'expert numéro 1!
Foutaises!
-C'est qui celui-là?
- Le gamin qui joue Bobby enfant.
-Eh! Descends de là, petit!
-Je vais le chercher!
On n'est pas prêts pour ta scène!
Attendez les gars. J'aimerais
savoir ce qu'il a à nous dire.
Qu'est-ce que tu viens de dire?
J'ai dit "foutaises!"
Qu'est-ce qui est des foutaises?
Que vous le connaissez
mieux que tout le monde!
Génial! Un mini Bobby, acteur,
en plus! J'ai besoin d'un verre!
-Marrant, c'est Bobby tout craché!
-Oui, il lui ressemble vraiment!
Je reviens tout de suite!
Oh non, c'est reparti!
Alors c'est toi qui joues mon rôle!
Je ne joue pas, je suis toi!
Tu crois vraiment me connaître?
Je te connais mieux
qu'aucun d'entre eux!
Même en la refaisant cent fois, ce
ne sera jamais assez bon pour lui!
Qu'il s'en prenne à moi, ça je peux
l'admettre...
Mais qu'il crie sur les gars,non!
Ils bossent comme des fous pour lui!
Je n'ai jamais travaillé avec
un enfoiré aussi arrogant!
Ecoute-moi, petite merde!
Il y a quatre personnes, ici, qui
ne peuvent pas être renvoyées!
Et toi, tu ne fais pas partie
des quatre!
C'est peut-être bien un enfoiré,
mais c'est pour lui qu'on bosse!
Regardez! Il s'est trouvé lui-même!
On devrait commencer par quoi alors?
Tu veux de la vérité?
Je vais te donner de la vérité!
Attends! Cours pas si vite!
Le gamin a raison.
C'est là qu'il faut commencer.
Dans la rue où j'ai grandi avec ma
soeur Nina, mon beau-frère Charlie,
et la personne la plus importante
à mes yeux, ma mère Polly.
Madame Cassotto, je suis désolé de
devoir vous l'annoncer...
Votre fils souffre de rhumatisme
articulaire.
- Qu'est-ce que c'est?
- Une sorte d'infection aiguë.
Pourquoi c'est si douloureux?
Le rhumatisme articulaire
endommage le coeur.
Cela affecte aussi les
articulations et les muscles.
Que peut-on faire pour le
soulager, Docteur?
Donnez-lui simplement
tout le confort possible.
Dites-nous la vérité!
La vérité est
toujours une bonne chose!
Même avec le meilleur
traitement médical au monde,
il aura beaucoup de chance s'il
atteint ses quinze ans!
Qu'est-ce que tu fais là, Bobby?
Allons viens dans mes bras. Cet
homme ne sait pas de quoi il parle.
Il faut te recoucher, viens!
Maman, parle-moi de mon père!
Allons, tu sais déjà tout à son
sujet! Dors, maintenant!
Mais j'adore
quand tu me parles de lui!
Eh bien... Sam Cassotto était un
homme très important.
C'était un excellent ébéniste!
Mais un jour il s'est mis à
travailler pour un autre homme.
-Qui était un gangster.
-Walden Robert Cassotto!
C'était un homme d'affaires!
Je croyais que tu disais que la
vérité était toujours bonne à dire!
Ok, tu as raison. Mais pour notre
famille, il n'a jamais rien fait!
Ton père, par contre, Sam Cassotto
était un homme loyal et généreux.
Et il aurait été très fier de toi!
Et ne faites pas de bruit! Je
veux que ce soit une surprise.
Ne réveillez pas le gosse!
Ca va pas, non? Que fichez-vous au
milieu de la rue! Imbéciles!
Si tu réveilles mon gosse, je te
fous ton klaxon dans le cul!
Tu sais, avant la naissance de ta
soeur, je gagnais ma vie comme ça!
La musique m'a ouvert les portes
d'un tout nouveau monde!
Même si je me sens mal, que je sois
triste ou malade,
il suffit que je pose mes doigts
sur ces touches et pouh!...
Comme par magie, tout de suite je
me sens nettement mieux!
J'ai toujours su que tu avais du
talent, Bobby! Ce piano est à toi!
Charlie a travaillé dur
pour l'acheter!
Dieu t'a fait souffrir, mais il
comptait se rattraper plus tard!
Maman avait raison
au sujet de la musique :
elle m'ouvrit
les portes d'un monde nouveau,
extérieur au temps et à la maladie.
Un monde où je pouvais vivre.
Je savais que si
j'atteignais les dix ans,
je pourrais peut-être atteindre les
quinze, puis même les vingt ans!
De ce moment, la musique devint la
chose la plus importante de ma vie.
Maman me montra les pas qu'elle
avait appris dans les vaudevilles
qui faisaient se démarquer
les grands artistes.
Je passais la plupart de mes
journées cloué au lit par la fièvre,
mais dès que j'en avais la force,
on s'exerçait encore et encore!
Jusqu'à ce que soit créé
ce qu'elle appela "Le Plan!"
J'allais bientôt être assez
grand pour aller à New York,
mais maman avait
encore quelque chose à m'apprendre
Quoi?
Tu n'as pas dansé dans la rue
comme ça!
Je le sais! C'est de la fantaisie,
de l'imaginaire!
- Mais ce n'est pas vrai!
- Oublie la réalité!
Ecoute, gamin! Les souvenirs sont
comme des rayons de lune.
On en fait ce qu'on veut!
Ok, dans ce cas, continue!
Je reste dans le coin si t'as
besoin de moi!
Une partie du plan de ma mère,
c'était de m'entourer des meilleurs!
Du coup, j'ai eu un manager qui
n'avait jamais fait ça de sa vie :
Steve "Boum Boum" Blauner.
Un attaché aux relations publiques
qui n'avait jamais eu de relations
avec le public : David Gershenson
Dick Berke, qui n'avait jamais
dirigé que l'orchestre du lycée,
et mon beau-frère Charlie, éboueur,
comme serviteur.
Ce n'est plus l'orchestre du Lycée,
hein Bobby!
Quand on vient de rien comme nous,
ou lui, là,
on n'a pas d'autre choix que de se
faire un nom
C'est ce qu'on va faire, Richie. Et
on y arrivera.
Va là-bas! Va jusqu'à ces nanas
là-bas! Allez, va! Va! Va!
Hé les filles!
Vous voulez voir une vraie star?
Et donc, pendant que Sinatra jouait
à guichet fermé au Copa,
Walden Robert Cassotto se produisait
partout où on l'engageait :
aux Bar Mitzvhahs, mariages,
et quelques rades de Long Island.
- Eh gamin! T'es pas Sinatra
- Stop! Stop!
Ce sont des paresseux!
Ils n'aiment pas répéter!!
Ils ne s'améliorent pas en
répétant! Je perds mon temps!
- Ce n'est que le Safari-Club!
- Peu importe!
Vire les, Bobby! Ils ne sont pas à
ta hauteur!
Sur deux de nos trois chansons, ils
ne tiennent même pas le rythme!
La semaine dernière, tu savais
pas ce qu'était un fa dièse,
- Maintenant t'es un expert?
- Oui, je suis un expert!
Bobby, tu as dit toi-même que le
Safari Club était une infection!
Moi, je vous ai trouvé très bien!
Non! On a joué comme de la merde et
le public mérite bien mieux!
J'étais une tête brûlée,
avec un coeur fragile
et un très mauvais nom de scène.
"Walden Robert Cassatto" n'a pas
vraiment sa place sur un auvent!
Ou alors peut-être seulement pour
un soir!
A l'époque, un artiste se devait
d'avoir un super nom de scène.
Et un jour... je le vis. Le nom
parfait! Qui clignotait :
Dès que j'eus changé de nom, je fis
mon premier passage à la télévision.
Malheureusement, je ne connaissais
pas les paroles
de la chanson que j'avais choisi de
chanter
Je conçus donc une technique
personnelle pour réussir ce direct.
Ca ne m'a pas gagné beaucoup de
fans!
Mais ça n'a pas non plus signé la
fin de ma carrière.
Ma maison de disques me donna
une dernière chance de percer.
Bobby! Tout est une question
d'image, pas vrai?
Laisse-moi un peu tranquille! C'est
ma dernière session!
T'as vraiment un look de chiottes!
Je sais que je perds mes cheveux!
Je me vois tous les jours!
La prochaine fois que tu fais
une télé mets un postiche!
- Ce serait une imposture!
- John Wayne en porte un.
Trouve donc plus honnête que lui!
Humphrey Bogart aussi.
Oh! Bogart aussi prépare un disque?
Sinatra en porte un aussi.
Ok, Boum-Boum, tu as gagné!
Et maintenant faut que je retourne
là-bas faire le vinyle
et puis mettre la cire dans le truc
pour que ça fonctionne.
Faut que je recommence cette
chanson. Salut.
Cette chanson a du sens, pour toi?
Elle se passe dans les toilettes!
On s'en fiche du sens!
Ce serait mieux dans une douche au
lieu d'une baignoire!
- Un mec ne prend pas de bain!
- C'est vrai ça!
Je me drape dans la serviette, je
ressaute dans la baignoire, et puis?
Il veut ressauter dans la baignoire?
Il les connaît, ces gens?
Où veux-tu qu'il aille d'autre?
Non, non, on va jouer avec ça un
peu plus longtemps.
Joue tant que tu veux, mais
rappelle-toi, une heure, pas plus!
Eh, c'est qui ce gars, Yom Kippur,
qui réserve le studio le vendredi?
Regardez-le! Il a dit qu'il y
arriverait et ça y est!
Il va devenir la plus
grande star du show-business!
M'man! Pousse-toi, s'te plaît, je
vois rien!
Qu'est-ce qu'il a sur la tête?
Qu'est-ce que c'est?
C'est un toupet! Un postiche!
Je fus l'idole des jeunes pendant
une minute et demi.
Mais Maman voulait que
je sois plus célèbre que Sinatra!
Je voulais reprendre les grands
standards du jazz,
mais mon producteur me disait de ne
pas tourner le dos au Rock'n Roll
Les teenagers n'achèteront jamais
un album où tu fais des reprises!
Non, pas encore! Comment tu sais ça?
T'as une boule de cristal, là?
Je m'y connais! On ne change pas
son image quand on est au top!
Je ne veux pas des teenagers comme
seul public alors c'est parfait!
Pourquoi n'es-tu pas satisfait? Tu
viens de faire un tabac!
Devant des gosses!
Ahmet, je veux le Copa!
En faisant du rock, je suis comme
tous les autres, tu le sais!
Je vais prouver que je sais chanter!
Je veux tout!
Les meilleures salles, les clubs,
Vegas, le cinéma, la télé...
Avec cet album ça ira très vite,
plus vite que tu ne l'imagines!
Mais tu n'as rien à prouver!
Tu es déjà une grande star!
- Tu crois vraiment?
- Mais oui!
Une seconde! Eh, toi! Attends une
seconde! Toi, là-bas!
Je n'ai pas de temps à perdre,
Bobby!
Viens là, une seconde. Juste une
question, tu veux? Regarde-moi.
- Quoi?
- Regarde-moi.
- Tu me connais?
- Quoi?
- Tu me reconnais?
- De quoi vous parlez?
- Mon visage t'est-il familier?
- Non! Pas du tout!
Je ne vous connais pas! Maintenant
laissez-moi, j'ai du boulot!
Merci, vieux!
Ahmet, quand le livreur me
reconnaîtra, là je serai une star.
Cyprès deux - six, sept, deux.
Bobby, retiens ce numéro.
Si tu as besoin de moi...
Où que tu sois...
Appelle-moi. Cyprès deux
- six, sept, deux.
Réponds-moi!
Tu dois raconter
ce qui s'est passé après.
Hey! Nina! Comment va?
Bobby, j'ai quelque chose à te dire.
Quoi?
Vas-y! Il faut que tu y ailles!
T'inquiète pas pour moi!
Je ne peux pas!
Il le faut.
Maman, Je crois que c'est celui
que nous voulions
Le voici! Le grand Bobby Darin!
Meilleur nouvel artiste!
Meilleur album!
En route pour Hollywood!
Ainsi, avec le succès, Hollywood
vint frapper à la porte.
Je m'envolai pour l'Italie avec
Charlie et Nina
pour faire un film avec Rock Hudson
et Sandra Dee.
C'est quoi ton problème,
espèce de stupide rital!
Il a des choses fragiles là-dedans!
Mon Dieu!
- Nina.
- Je suis désolée, mais je...
- Nina, calme-toi s'il te plaît!
- je vais le faire moi-même.
Regarde qui est en couverture
de "Screen magazine", Charlie!
Non pas ça, laissez ça tranquille!
- C'est génial!
- Nina! On va faire un tour!
- Un film!
- T'as deviné!
- Tu sais jouer la comédie?
- J'ai fait ça toute ma vie!
Un, deux, trois.
C'est quoi, ton voeu?
Faut pas le dire
si on veut que ça se réalise!
J'espère que tu auras ce que tu
veux.
C'est vraiment gentil!
Coupez! Parfait!
C'est dans la boîte?
On va manger, on reprend après.
Change de bobine.
Sandy, est-ce que ça te dirait de
dîner avec moi ce soir?
Non, merci. Je vais dîner dans
ma chambre et me coucher tôt.
Oh mon Dieu! Et tu supportes ce
genre de soirées trépidantes?
Je ne suis pas ici pour m'amuser
mais pour travailler!
Peut-être que toi aussi,
tu devrais te coucher tôt!
Et qu'est-ce qui te fait dire
que ce n'est pas le cas?
Sandra Dee, est-ce que vous
m'espionnez, par hasard?
Je n'ai jamais travaillé avec
quelqu'un d'aussi peu professionnel!
- Tu as déjà fais ça, avant?
- Je suis en train d'apprendre.
Mais laisse-moi te dire un truc,
toi tu n'as rien d'Audrey Hepburn!
Ok tout le monde! Pause repas!
Une heure!
- Poupou! comment va, gamin?
- C'est Pompom et c'est une femelle!
Sandy, ne laisse pas ton chien
ruiner ton beau maquillage!
Dites, Mary, il y a une chose que
je ne comprends pas.
- J'aimerais que vous m'expliquiez.
- Quoi?
Comment se fait-il que vous soyez
la mère de Sandy et non sa soeur?
Monsieur Darin!
Non, sérieusement!
vous êtes le parfait miroir
l'une de l'autre!
Quand tu souris, il faut que le
sourire reste léger.
C'est ça, pas plus,
sinon tu auras des petites rides.
Regarde, c'est elle, Charlie,
la fille que je vais épouser.
Je veux que tu me trouves un bon
fleuriste.
Je veux lui faire livrer chaque
jour dix-huit roses jaunes.
Pas de carte. Elle saura
qui les envoie.
Je lui donne une semaine, peut-être
moins.
Je crois que très vite, Mary cèdera.
Tu vas envoyer ces roses à la mère?
On doit s'assurer les faveurs de la
chienne avant d'approcher son petit!
Mary n'a rien de Rin-tin-tin!
C'est une femme de caractère!
Et elle a une star à protéger.
Tu vas avoir des ennuis!
Ces ennuis-là, je peux les gérer.
Ton fleuriste va se faire plus de
fric que toi sur ce tournage!
Souviens-toi : pour jouer bien,tu
dois aussi avoir ça en tête:
Tu dois te demander comment sont tes
lèvres, si on voit tes dents.
Ok! Tout le monde sur le plateau!
Sandy et moi avions juste démarré
du mauvais pied.
Si je pouvais seulement l'éloigner
de sa mère!
Je veux dire, imaginez:
Bobby Darin et Sandra Dee!
Sandy, nous avons une séance photo
dans moins d'une heure!
Je veux que tu mettes l'ensemble que
le studio a envoyé de Paris. Venez!
C'est ça! Je vais recommencer du
début.
Comme si on ne s'était jamais
rencontré.
Mais cette fois, je la charmerai à
ma façon!
Bonjour Sandra Dee, je suis Bobby
Darin.
Je crois que nous allons tourner
ensemble.
Bonjour!
Sandy! On doit y aller, maintenant!
J'ai une interview.
Dis-leur que t'as rencontré Bobby
Darin et qu'il va t'épouser!
- Allez viens, Pompom!
- Joli chapeau, Monsieur Darin!
Je crois bien qu'elle m'apprécie,
Charlie!
La mère?
Ca, c'est une autre histoire!
Elle ne fait que son job!
De quel job tu parles?
Tenir sa fille éloignée de gars de
ton genre!
Ouais! Eh ben tu veux que je dise,
Charlie?
Le job de MA mère était bien plus
compliqué!
Ca c'est bien mon gamin!
Alors, j'ai lu que vous avez une
très haute opinion de vous-même
Eh bien, Madame Duvan,
j'ai été élevé dans l'idée
qu'il faut avoir un objectif dans
la vie.
Alors une fois que j'ai pris une
décision,
je vais jusqu'au bout.
Vous voulez bien m'excuser une
seconde?
Je crois que Sandy a un peu froid.
Vous savez, Madame Duvan... Mary...
Je trouve votre fille absolument
magnifique.
Il n'y a pas plus belle qu'elle sur
terre!
Mais elle n'est encore qu'une
enfant!
Vous, il vous faut une femme plus
mûre!
Je veux juste qu'on soit amis,
si on doit tourner ensemble.
Mais elle n'a même pas l'air de
m'apprécier!
Il faut lui laisser du temps!
Elle a toujours été un peu timide!
J'ai une idée! Je pourrais
sortir avec elle un soir!
Pour un tête à tête?
Non, non! Pour la pub!
Une seule fois!
Je ne l'ai jamais laissé faire
une chose pareille!
Pensez à la promotion que ça
ferait pour le film!
- Une seule fois!
Pourquoi pas. Juste
pour la promotion du film!
Je vous jure, Sandra Dee, une
fidélité éternelle,
à vous, la Reine du Cinéma!
Et moi je vous nomme chevalier
Splish Splash.
Relevez-vous, chevalier Splish
Splash!
Comment c'était, les gars?
Quelles sont vos relations avec vos
partenaires?
- Parlez-nous de Rock Hudson!
- Oui, Rock Hudson, comment est-il?
Tout va très bien, Rock
Hudson est fantastique, pas vrai?
Fantastique!
- On va semer ces clowns!
- Quoi?
Quand je dirai "cours" tu pars en
courant.
- Comment vous vous sentez ici?
- L'Italie, c'est magnifique!
Vous prévoyez de tourner
d'autres films ensemble?
Oh mon Dieu! Oh mon Dieu!
Cours! Cours!
Attends!
Ca va?
Je n'en reviens pas d'avoir fait ça!
Tu es magnifique!
Viens!
Ca va? Je te trouve plutôt pâle!
Oh non, ça va! J'ai juste des
baisses d'énergie, parfois.
Etre dans un si vieil endroit, ça
fait réfléchir!
Pendant des siècles, des gens ont
vécu ici, se sont aimé ici...
ils ont combattu, sont morts...
Et maintenant nous sommes là, toi
et moi.
Quel genre de choses tu apprécies?
Je pense à une chose en particulier,
là, tout de suite!
- Sois sérieux!
- Attends, je dois réfléchir un peu!
Une belle mélodie
Voir quelqu'un faire quelque chose
à la perfection.
La crème glacée!
Un bon livre... A toi, maintenant.
Qu'est-ce qui plaît à Sandra Dee?
Les longues marches sur la plage.
Faire des mots croisés
Les plateaux de cinéma vides.
Elvis.
Je voulais juste voir si tu me
prêtais attention!
Je te prête attention, crois-moi!
Je ne m'étais pas trompé à ton
sujet!
Comment ça?
Ca va être facile de t'aimer!
Voulez-vous m'accorder cette danse,
Mademoiselle Sandra Dee?
J'en serais très honorée, Bobby
Darin!
Espèce de salaud!
J'ai eu pitié de vous, et vous
avez trahi ma confiance!
Mary, vous exagérez!
Je vous ai dit que vous pouviez
emmener ma fille en promenade!
Pour les journalistes!
Pas pour l'épouser!
Maman! Pour l'instant,
nous ne sommes que fiancés!
Toi tu viens avec moi!
Assise!
Tu ne sais même pas comment te
coiffer, sans moi!
Tu ne sais pas t'habiller sans moi!
Tu ne sais pas comment marcher ni
comment parler aux gens sans moi!
Je t'ai fait entrer dans cet
univers! C'est moi qui t'ai créée!
Tu tomberas en miettes en moins
de deux sans moi!
Oh maman, je t'en prie, arrête!
Le jour venu, quand tu seras prête
on te trouvera un mari convenable
avec une bonne situation
Qu'est-ce qui se passe?
Mais je l'aime, maman!
- Je l'aime de tout mon coeur!
- Ce n'est qu'un looser!
Non, pas du tout! Il est charmant
et il me fait rire!
J'aurais aimé que tu te concentres
davantage sur Rock Hudson!
Rock Hudson est très sympa mais je
ne suis pas amoureuse de lui!
Il aurait été un meilleur mari pour
toi que ce Bobby Darin!
Laisse-moi prendre une décision
toute seule, pour une fois!
Je ne veux même pas en discuter plus
longtemps! On s'en va!
C'est lui ou moi!
Parfait! Donne-la moi!
J'ai dit donne-la moi!
Mary! Attendez une petite seconde!
Nina! Bon Dieu! Reste ici! Ne te
mêles pas de ça!
- C'est pas tes oignons!
- Mary, je voudrais vous parler!
- Vous projetez d'avoir des enfants?
- Pas encore!
Montrez nous la bague!
Pour quand le mariage?
Le mariage est une si grande étape!
Nous avons décidé de ne pas
précipiter les choses!
- Pas vrai, chéri?
- Bien sûr! Absolument!
Nous avons décidé de prendre notre
temps, Messieurs! Absolument!
On y est! Ceci est ta maison.
Je serai ravi d'inviter ici
quelques amis de temps en temps,
et quand ta mère voudra venir, ce
qui finira certainement par arriver,
elle sera la bienvenue elle aussi!
Mais pour le moment, je pense qu'on
devrait rester seuls tous les deux :
Monsieur et Madame Bobby Darin dans
leur demeure.
Où es-tu passée?
Tu es déjà entrée dans la chambre?
Sandy, où es-tu?
Eh bien ma chérie!
Chérie, ce devrait être le plus
beau soir de ta vie!
Allez, viens, lève-toi. Sortons
d'ici. Viens.
Non, non, je... je ne peux pas,
non! Je ne peux pas!
Tu ne peux pas quoi?
- Je ne peux pas aller plus loin!
- Bien sûr que tu peux, ma belle!
- Non, je ne peux pas!
- Mais si tu peux!
Tu n'aurais pas dû m'épouser!
Je suis ton mari, et le resterai
jusqu'à ce que la mort nous sépare!
Comment peux-tu épouser quelqu'un
que tu ne connais pas?
C'est moi qui ne te connais pas ou
c'est toi qui ne me connais pas?
Je ne sais pas si je te connais,
mais je sais que tu ne me connais
pas!
Oh si, je te connais, tu es Madame
Bobby Darin!
Ca ne marchera pas, Bobby!
Arrêtons tout de suite!
Hors de question!
Tu ne seras jamais heureux avec moi!
Tu ne comprends donc rien?
Je veux qu'on en reste là!
Je refuse de te rendre malheureux!
Oh mon Dieu!
Quoi?
Je t'aime!
Je t'aime tellement!
Attends une seconde! Attends-moi!
Ne bouge pas! Ne bouge pas!
Mon Dieu, Bobby! Non! Pitié!
Chérie! Calme-toi, ma belle!
Tout va bien. Je ne vais rien te
faire du tout!
Je la pose, d'accord?
Ma maman me racontait souvent une
histoire quand j'étais petit.
Au Moyen-âge,
un des chevaliers du Roi Arthur
avait déposé son épée au milieu du
lit entre lui-même et Guenièvre.
Et il avait juré qu'il ne passerait
jamais de l'autre côté du lit.
C'est vrai?
Je dépose cette épée entre nous
deux.
Celui-ci est mon côté du lit.
Et celui-là c'est le tien.
Et je ne passerai jamais de l'autre
côté de l'épée. Jamais.
Peu m'importe qu'on ne se touche
pas pendant mille nuits!
Toi seule pourras franchir l'épée
pour venir de mon côté!
Toi seule.
- Il fait quand même deux pages!
- Je t'aurais cru plus modeste!
- Il en a pas mal rajouté!
- Joli coup de pub!
La prochaine fois, essaie de
limiter les dégâts!
- Tu es présenté comme un requin!
- C'est pas de ma faute.
Comment, c'est pas de ta faute?
C'est toi qui menais la barque!
- Hello chéri!
- Hé! Ma belle!
Regarde qui est en couverture!
Chérie, c'est génial! Tu as vu ça?
"Je veux être une légende". Je ne
peux pas croire que tu aies dis ça!
Disons que ce n'est pas exactement
ce que j'ai dit!
La prochaine fois, obtiens-lui la
couverture!
Allons, c'est un super article,
Blauner!
Attendez, la suite est encore mieux!
"Bravache, impudent et arrogant,
Darin ajoute :
"Je souhaite surpasser Sinatra
dans absolument tous les domaines!"
Et maintenant, messieurs-dames,
pour la première fois sur notre
scène
"Bravache, Impudent et arrogant!"
Ressors-la, la prochaine fois qu'on
joue quelque part!
Promis! Eh, quels sont tes projets?
On sera où dans cinq ans?
Va savoir. D'ici-là les Russes
pourraient être Rois du business!
Tu dis n'importe quoi, Boum-Boum!
Dis-moi plutôt ce qui se passera
dans une semaine, un mois, un an!
Dans un an je ne sais pas, mais
je sais où nous serons dans un mois!
Pitié! Ne me dis pas que c'est à
Détroit!
Tout le monde me déteste dans le
show business
à cause des contrats que je négocie.
D'après vous, les gars, c'est pour
ça qu'on le déteste?
Au fait, puisqu'on parle justement
des projets futurs...
Bobby, j'ai failli oublier de te le
dire :
Il va nous falloir un comédien pour
ta première partie au Copa!
Répète ce que tu viens de dire!
Je t'avais rien dit?
On va jouer au Copa.
Tu te fiches de moi?
Ca m'a été confirmé ce matin.
Nom de Dieu, c'est génial!
- Ca y est! On joue au Copa!
- On va cartonner!
Boum Boum t'es un génie!
Quel fou furieux!
Sandy! Je vais jouer...
Je vais jouer au Copa! Je vais
jouer au Copa! On joue au Copa!
Mon rêve est enfin devenu réalité!
On joue au Copa!
C'est génial, chéri!
Mais c'est quoi, le Copa?
Le Copacabana est le night-club le
plus important du monde!
Tous les gens célèbres ont joué
ici.
Et un jour c'est toi qui joueras
ici, Bobby!
Et crois-moi, tu feras encore plus
d'entrées que Sinatra!
Georges Kerby est le comique le
plus drôle de notre temps.
Je n'ai jamais dit qu'il n'était
pas drôle!
J'ai dit que c'était un négro.
- Il a beaucoup de succès!
- Ecoutez!
Si c' était une star comme Sammy
Davis, il aurait sa place ici.
Mais jamais, et vous le savez très
bien,
il ne pourra faire l'ouverture du
Copa!
Ecoutez, Monsieur Podell, il y
a une première fois à tout!
Pourquoi ne pas laisser un des plus
grands comédiens du pays jouer ici?
Parce que j'ai dit non!
C'est la politique de la maison,
vous comprenez?
Je comprends, mais au diable la
politique de votre maison!
On est en 1960 aujourd'hui,
pas 1860!
On m'a dit que vous n'aviez pas la
langue dans votre poche!
Gardez-la donc pour chanter!
Je respecte le fait que ce soit
votre club, je vous assure,
mais si vous refusez que Georges
Kirby fasse ma première partie,
je vous assure que cela aura de
fâcheuses conséquences!
Des menaces?
Je ne fais que vous mettre en
garde, Monsieur Podell!
Vous savez ce qu'est un sit-in!
Un sit- quoi?
C'est une forme de protestation
très populaire aujourd'hui.
Les membres d'une communauté,
qu'elle soit noire ou blanche,
en fait elles sont souvent
ensemble aujourd'hui,
se réunissent dans un établissement
qu'ils considèrent être, disons...
discriminatoire envers leurs frères
et soeurs.
Et puis les média se pointent,
ils forment une chaîne humaine, et
puis ils s'asseyent!
Parfois pendant plusieurs jours.
Ils s'asseyent!
Oui, ils s'asseyent.
Et ils chantent.
Des chansons du genre... comment,
déjà?
"Nous triompherons".
"Nous triompherons"?
Mais triompher de quoi?
Des politiques, Monsieur Podell!
Des politiques dépassées!
Merci beaucoup! Je ne sais pas si
vous avez remarqué
cette merveilleuse chose qu'est
la télévision de nos jours.
J'avais Hollywood, en Californie,
sur une de mes chaînes
Parmi tous les présentateurs,
ma préférée était Louella Parsons.
Je n'oublierai jamais comment elle
commençait son émission :
"Bien le bonsoir d'Hollywood!"
Apparemment, je ne suis pas le seul
à en avoir été marqué!
- Et je veux juste aller le saluer.
- C'est impossible.
- Vous n'avez pas à me dire ça!
Je sais où je vais!
Inutile de vous énerver!
- Laissez-moi passer!
- Retournez dans la salle, Madame.
Vous n'avez pas à me dire où je
dois aller!
Je vais là-bas, au fond voir
M.Darin! Je suis sa soeur!
Vous n'avez pas d'ordre à me
donner! Je sais ce que j'ai à faire.
Nina! Qu'est-ce qui se passe?
Ces imbéciles m'empêchent de passer
pour venir te voir!
Je suis de la famille et ils me
traitent comme une vulgaire fan!
Chérie, ils sont obligés
de ne pas laisser circuler
n'importe qui en coulisses à cette
heure-ci.
Oh bien entendu! Parce que je suis
n'importe qui?
Non, tu n'es pas... Les gars,
laissez-nous deux minutes.
Je dois me préparer à entrer sur
scène.
- Pourquoi on est encore au fond?
- Mais de quoi tu parles?
Ma table est quasiment dans la
cuisine!
Tu veux peut-être que je t'apporte
le café pendant que j'y serais!
Les tables devant sont réservées
aux gars et aux gens du métier!
J'ai vu Sandy, elle est assise
tout devant!
Ils voulaient qu'elle soit assise
là, tout devant.
Avoue-le! Ma présence et celle de
Charlie te gênent!
Mais pas du tout, chérie!
Ce sont les tables de Podell, ce
n'est pas moi qui décide!
- Tu dis n'importe quoi! Foutaises!
- C'est pas n'importe quoi!
Allez, va profiter du spectacle!
C'est le soir le plus important de
toute ma vie!
Je ferai de mon mieux, même si je
ne vois rien!
Je demanderai au chef de salle
comment ça s'est passé!
Mesdames et messieurs, voici Bobby
Darin!
Merci beaucoup!
Merci et bienvenue au Copacabana!
A la direction musicale, Mesdames
et Messieurs, Richie Berke!
Je suis très honoré d'être ici, ce
soir, au Copacabana.
J'ai toujours rêvé
de me produire ici.
Je voudrais profiter de l'occasion
pour
rendre hommage aux deux femmes de
ma vie.
Ma mère, Polly, qui a toujours rêvé
et cru
qu'un jour, je me produirais
au Copacabana.
Et donc cette soirée est
pour elle. Pour ma mère.
Et l'autre femme est ici ce soir.
C'est bien sûr ma très chère
jeune épouse, Sandra Dee.
La femme que vous regardez
pendant que j'essaie de travailler!
Ah! Regardez ça! Elle rougit!
Merci de l'accueil chaleureux,
Mesdames et messieurs!
Et maintenant j'aimerais chanter
spécialement pour elle.
Je veux dédier cette chanson à celle
qui a profondément changé ma vie
Allez, viens.
Je t'aime, Sandy!
Après toutes ces années, il semble
que Bobby Darin et Sandra Dee
soient devenus le couple le plus
célèbre de la planète.
Après la naissance de Dodd Mitchell
Cassotto, le 16 décembre,
ils se sont installé à Los Angeles
pour y tourner des films.
Sandra dans un nouvel épisode de
"Tammy"
et Bobby, en second rôle dans "Le
combat du Capitaine Newman".
Silence!
Je suis désolé.
Ok? Silence sur le plateau!
Et... Action, Bobby!
D'accord Big Jim!
Tu y vas et tu me fais décoller ces
deux vieux coucous du sol, ok?
On devrait se taper quelques
minettes une fois rentré chez nous!
Des nanas avec de gros nibards, tu
vois ce que je veux dire?
Je te parle d'énormes roberts! Ca
te plairait?
Dieu du ciel! Qu'est-ce que
c'était?
On a été touché!
Buck! Buck, on perd de l'altitude!
Dieu du ciel, on va s'écraser!
Il faut que je sorte, par la trappe
de secours!
Oh C'est pas vrai! Oh
non! Il n'a plus de tête!
Ô Dieu, je vous en prie, faites
qu'il redevienne comme avant!
Oh, mon Dieu! Non!
Coupez! Magnifique!
Bobby, tu as été fantastique!
Excusez-moi. Bobby!
Merci, c'était incroyable!
C'est le meilleur rôle que j'ai eu
à jouer!
Je t'avais dit que c'était un bon
script!
Tu ne peux que cartonner avec
un Gregory Peck et un Tony Curtis!
Et une Angie Dickinson!
N'oublie pas Angie! Merci Angie!
- Bye-bye! A bientôt!
Bon, et pour la suite?
Je n'en sais rien. Boum-boum, la
suite?
On va jouer à Tahoe pour trois
soirs, le vingt.
Ensuite on a Philadelphie, Chicago
et Miami Beach.
- Merci! Bonne chance!
- Merci beaucoup!
- Mais de quoi est-ce qu'il parle?
- De la tournée, ma belle!
Mais mon tournage n'est pas
encore terminé!
C'est pas grave! Dodd et toi vous
me rejoindrez quand tu auras fini!
Je ne vais pas emmener le bébé sur
les routes!
Dans ce cas, laisse-le à la nurse,
c'est pour ça qu'on l'a engagée!
Je ne veux pas que Dodd soit élevé
par la nurse!
Chérie! Il ne sera pas élevé par la
nurse!
Et moi, qu'est-ce que je vais faire
sur les routes?
Pour qui je vais chanter
si t'es pas là?
Il faut que j'y retourne.
- Ne sois pas fâchée!
- Je ne le suis pas!
- Tu as l'air fâchée!
Plus vite j'aurai fini mon film,
plus vite je vous rejoindrai.
Chéri! Ton toupet est légèrement de
travers!
Quoi?
Tu rigoles!
Les filles! Il faut faire plus
attention à mes cheveux!
Super timing, Steve! J'espérais
l'avoir un peu à la maison!
Ce sera un miracle si Dodd
reconnait son père!
Génial de les avoir tous les deux
dans le même studio, non?
Voici votre suite, Bobby et Madame
Darin.
Allez-y, entrez! Le bar
ici, là-bas la salle de bain...
- et le salon par ici.
- Oh! D'accord.
Je dépose vos bagages et reviens
dans une minute.
Regarde ça, chérie! Ca va être une
chaude nuit à Las Vegas!
- Autre chose pour vous servir?
- C'est tout pour le moment, merci.
Voulez-vous des glaçons ou autre
chose?
Non, non, c'est parfait comme ça.
Merci. Voici. Vous venez d'où?
- Je viens d'Allemagne.
- C'est une ville fantastique!
- Je suis un de vos grands fans!
- C'est très gentil. Bonne nuit.
Tu ne crois pas que tu bois
un peu trop ces derniers temps?
Non. Je crois que je n'ai pas assez
bu au contraire!
- Quel est le problème?
- Je voudrais qu'on soit ensemble!
Mais on est ensemble, ma belle,
regarde!
Je te parle d'un emploi du temps
plus normal!
Nous avons un bébé maintenant!
Si je te ne voyais pas sur scène, je
ne te verrais jamais!
Mais tu es tout le temps avec moi!
Pour les enregistrements, les
shows, les films, les mondanités!
On ne pourrait pas
juste être chez nous?
- Le spectacle, c'est toute ma vie!
- Mais et moi alors?
- Mais tu es là, non?
- Oui, avec toute ton équipe!
Ils font partie de ma vie,
comme Mary fait partie de ta vie et
maintenant de la nôtre!
Ils sont notre famille, tous, que
ça te plaise ou non!
J'ai aussi du travail, je ne peux
pas continuellement t'accompagner!
- Bien sûr que si!
- Non! Je suis une actrice!
Jouer dans des films c'est mon
métier à moi!
Embrasser Troy Donahue,
c'est pas un métier!
- Ah non? Eh bien alors essaye!
- Je préfère pas!
Quel beau visage!
- Tu devrais fermer la porte à clé.
- Mais non!
- Et si quelqu'un entrait!
- Personne ne va entrer.
Hier, Charlie est entré pendant que
j'étais sous la douche.
Tu rigoles? Qu'est-ce qu'il voulait?
Il voulait savoir si je voulais
un sandwich!
T'en veux un?
T'inquiète, on est tous seuls!
Bobby! Oh! Désolé! Mais j'avais
bien raison pour ce film de guerre!
Prépare ton discours! Dès la fin de
la tournée, tu files aux Oscars!
Tu viens d'être nominé!
Oh! Misère!
Et les nominés sont :
Nick Adams dans "Le motel du crime"
Bobby Darin dans
"Le combat du Capitaine Newman"
Melvyn Douglas dans
"Le plus sauvage d'entre tous"
Hugh Grifith dans "Tom Jones"
et John Huston dans "Le cardinal".
Et le gagnant est...
Je me suis donné corps et âme à ce
film
et ils donnent l'Oscar à Melvyn
Douglas!
Tu peux défaire ma robe s'il te
plaît?
"Tu te fiches pas mal des gens,
Hud! Tu les enverrais au diable!"
Il paraît qu'il est mourant.
C'est un vote de compassion!
Mourant? C'est moi qui suis mourant
et depuis plus longtemps que lui!
Et où est leur compassion
à mon égard?
Tu n'as jamais de scrupules à
toujours te lamenter sur ton sort?
"Mets ton doigt dans mon cul, Alma,
et tortille-le comme le docteur!"
C'est déjà un honneur d'être nominé!
Moi je n'ai jamais été nominée!
Tous tes fichus amis d'Hollywood!
C'est eux qui ont voté contre moi,
j'en suis sûr!
Moi j'ai voté pour toi!
C'est moi, le car est à quelle
heure? Okay, à demain.
Toutes ces tapes sur l'épaule, ces
sourires! J'ai été ridiculisé!
Tu n'étais pas aussi ridicule que tu
ne l'es en ce moment!
Waren Beatty est là avec Leslie
Caron, nominée meilleure actrice,
et moi, je suis là avec "Gidget"!
Leslie Caron ne vaut rien au Box
office!
- Ces gens-là s'en fichent pas mal!
- C'est ce qu'ils prétendent, Bobby!
Il n'y a que les gens du Bronx qui
font toute une histoire des Oscars!
Melvyn Douglas est marié à une
députée et moi je le suis à "Tammy"!
Il lui a fallu quarante ans
pour s'imposer et être reconnu.
Tu devrais être content
de l'avoir fait en deux ans!
Tu sais quoi? Je ferais mieux de
repartir en tournée!
Quelle idée magnifique, Bobby!
C'est vraiment une excellente idée!
Et comme d'habitude,
Dodd et moi on reste tous seuls!
Quand on est sur scène, c'est réel,
tu sens que le public est là!
Le public de cinéma est sans doute
trop sobre pour t'apprécier?
Non, je te répète que c'est réel!
Les night clubs c'est du réel!
C'est pas comme le cinéma où tout
est faux!
Je n'ai que ça à dire, Monsieur
Réalité, Monsieur le Roi du Réel:
ton fichu toupet est encore de
travers!
Tu fais tout le temps ça!
A me déstabiliser chaque fois que je
monte sur scène, comme ça...
à me dire que j'ai un bouton sur le
nez! c'est bon, j'en ai marre!
- Qu'est-ce que tu fabriques?
- A ton avis, ça ne se voit pas?
Non! Pas question!
Tu ne feras pas ça!
Tu ne me quitteras pas!
C'est moi qui te quitte!
Les bagnoles, les fringues, les
postiches, les premières,
c'est des conneries!
J'en ai marre de tout ça!
- Je laisse tomber et je me casse!
- Non! Tu restes ici!
Toi tu restes ici
pour t'occuper de Dodd!
La nurse est là, il ne craint rien!
Tu avais une chance d'être heureux
et tu l'as gâchée, pauvre idiot!
Non! Tu vas voir! Reviens ici!
Reviens ici tout de suite!
Tu crois que ça va être facile de
trouver quelqu'un qui t'aime?
Un petit merdeux prétentieux,
égocentrique, mesquin,
méchant, dégarni, avec un coeur
malade, comme toi?
Eh ben, tu peux toujours chercher,
parce que moi j'en veux plus!
Tu as peut-être raison
au sujet de tous ces gens qui nous
entourent constamment!
Peut-être qu'on devrait rester rien
que nous trois!
Ca tombe bien! Je ne savais plus où
je les avais posés!
Les années 1960 filèrent comme une
locomotive et Dodd grandissait.
Sandy et moi avons tourné quelques
films ensemble, tous des navets.
La scène musicale changea aussi
dramatiquement que le pays.
Les night-clubs passés de mode
furent remplacés par de grandes
scènes comme les stades.
J'étais soudain devenu hors sujet.
Les scènes où je me produisais
disparaissaient une à une.
J'essayai d'écrire de nouvelles
musiques et m'engageai en politique
parce que nous étions maintenant un
pays en guerre.
Mais à la vérité, j'étais
un chanteur à succès dégarni
qui n'avait plus fait un tube
depuis des années,
et qui aurait déjà dû être mort.
Et pourquoi Kennedy?
Comme la plupart des gens de ce
pays, j'en ai marre de cette folie!
L'assassinat de notre président, le
Vietnam, les émeutes.
Je suis en quête d'un remède à cette
folie
et voilà qu'apparaît cet autre
Bobby!
Voilà enfin quelqu'un de sérieux.
Un homme dévoué, passionné.
Il se soucie réellement du peuple.
Je le soutiens autant que je peux.
Je crois qu'il représente
le dernier espoir de ce pays.
Il a besoin de vos votes!
Et alors qu'il semblait que Bobby
Kennedy pourrait guérir le pays,
Sandy et moi nous éloignions de plus
en plus.
Bobby, pourquoi tu chantes les
mêmes chansons tous les soirs?
Ca doit être pelant à la longue!
C'est quoi ton souci, chérie? Tu
veux que je change chaque soir?
Pourquoi pas? Je ne fais pas chaque
fois les mêmes films!
Ben si justement, c'est ce que tu
fais! Des films à l'eau de rose...
Je suis bien placée pour savoir ce
que veut le public de nos jours!
Tu es peut-être l'expert en
musique, mais moi, moi...
j'ai des années d'expérience
au cinéma, je te signale!
Bien envoyé, Sandy!
Mais ce serait encore plus percutant
si tu articulais correctement.
Ma soeur était venue passer
quelques temps avec nous.
Mais je n'aurais jamais pu imaginer
la véritable raison de sa visite.
Ecoute, Bobby.
J'ai décidé de venir m'installer
ici pour une raison précise.
Oui. Laquelle?
Tu penses à t'investir dans la
politique, paraît-il?
On me l'a proposé alors j'y
réfléchis!
Tu sais que souvent la presse
s'acharne à discréditer les gens,
en fouillant dans leur passé, s'ils
prétendent accéder au pouvoir.
Oui, je sais et alors?
Il est grand temps que tu apprennes
un point important de ton passé.
De quoi est-ce que tu parles?
C'est au sujet de Polly.
Elle n'était pas celle que tu
croyais, Bobby!
Elle était la meilleure mère du
monde! Qu'est-ce qui te prend?
C'était une mère merveilleuse.
C'était ma mère et je le sais!
Alors retire ce que tu as dit!
C'était vraiment une personne
magnifique et une mère merveilleuse!
Mais ce dont tu as besoin
aujourd'hui, c'est de la vérité.
De la vérité sur ta mère.
Et la vérité, c'est que...
Polly n'était pas ta mère.
Sam n'était pas ton père.
Tu n'es pas mon frère, Bobby.
Nous avons juré de tout faire pour
que tu ne le découvres jamais.
Polly était ma mère.
Pas la tienne.
Elle était ta grand-mère.
Mon coeur
Je ne suis pas ta soeur!
Je suis ta mère!
Nous avons juré de ne jamais te le
dire.
C'est un canular!
Elle est tombée enceinte à dix-sept
ans!
C'est vrai, Bobby. Je ne
voulais pas que tu sois un bâtard.
Je t'ai donné à maman pour que
personne ne dise que tu en étais un!
Elle ne voulait pas te confier à
l'adoption!
Quand je suis allée à l'hôpital,
pour ta naissance,
Maman a déménagé dans le Bronx, où
personne ne nous connaissait.
A mon retour, on a dit à tous que tu
étais son bébé, pas le mien!
Mais au moins,
tu restais près de moi!
Tu réalises ce que tu es en train
de me dire?
Il fallait qu'on te protège, Bobby!
Tu as besoin de moi aujourd'hui. Je
veux être présente à tes côtés.
Tu peux enfin avoir la mère que tu
n'as jamais vraiment eue!
Qui était mon père?
A cette époque, j'enchaînais les
amants!
Je veux savoir qui était mon père!
Le sénateur finit son discours et se
dirigera vers la salle de presse.
Non, ça a changé, on va passer par
là!
On vient de tirer sur le Sénateur
Kennedy! Ce n'est pas possible!
Ce n'est pas possible!
C'est affreux!
Charlie!
Comment tu vas? Bien?
Je ne peux pas monter sur scène et
chanter les mêmes vieilles conneries
alors que des milliers de jeunes
Américains se font tuer
dans des champs de riz de l'autre
côté de la planète!
Le gouvernement nous a menti! On
nous ment tous les jours, Charlie!
Il n'y a pas de fin à cette guerre!
Le président nous a menti!
Toutes les personnes en qui on avait
confiance nous ont menti.
- Tu es un peu énervé en ce moment!
- Non, c'est pas ça!
Bobby Kennedy prônait la vérité.
Et regarde ce qu'ils lui ont fait!
Et regarde ce qu'il a fait du temps
où il était là!
Il n'a pas gaspillé ce temps!
Mais qu'est-ce que tu fais ici, toi?
Sandy dit que tu lui manques.
Dodd aussi.
Tu as rencontré Nina en quelle
année?
J'en sais rien. Dix neuf cent
trente et des poussières.
Tu sais qui est mon père, Charlie?
Non, Bobby. Je n'en sais rien.
J'aimerais tellement savoir qui il
était!
Je sais bien que je ne suis qu'un
petit ouvrier, mais...
j'ai toujours eu le sentiment que
c'était moi, ton père!
Charlie, tu as été mieux qu'un père
pour moi, tu le sais!
J'aimerais juste savoir.
Si tu restes ici plus longtemps,
Dodd va se poser la même question!
C'est vrai que tu ne sais pas qui
est ton père
mais en attendant tu as eu deux
mères à tes côtés!
Et toutes les deux
sont remarquables.
Tu as pensé à combien ça a été dur
pour Nina?
De ne pouvoir dire à personne que
tu étais son fils?
Si tu veux savoir qui tu es
vraiment, remonte sur scène!
- Tu es Bobby Darin!
- C'est ce que je croyais aussi.
Ok, ok, dans ce cas, tu es Walden
Robert Cassotto.
C'est pas vrai, Charlie. J'suis
même pas ce type là!
T'es peut-être tout bêtement les
deux!
Allez, Boum-Boum, on a un
concert à donner!
On y va! En route!
Je vais leur dire, je n'ai ni mère,
ni père, je n'ai que moi seul!
Hé! Chante "Dream Lover"!
Chante nous "Splish Splash"!
Qu'est-ce que c'est que ça?
Il trouve ça drôle?
T'es en train de devenir un vrai
hippie!
Tu sais je n'ai plus beaucoup de
temps devant moi, je suis mourant!
Arrête un peu ton cirque!
Tout ça c'est des conneries, Bobby!
C'est pas des conneries, c'est
seulement la vérité!
- On est tous mortels, Bobby!
- Je te parle pas de ça, tu le sais!
Chaque jour que je vis est
un miracle de la médecine moderne!
Je sais, tu n'étais pas censé
atteindre l'âge de seize ans!
- Ne te moque pas de moi!
- Je ne me moque pas de toi!
Comment je suis censé réagir quand
tu me sors toujours le même refrain?
Ils m'ont hué, Steve! Ils m'ont hué
jusqu'à me faire quitter la scène!
Comme si je leur avais volé leurs
quinze derniers fichus dollars!
Ils veulent entendre "Dream Lover"!
Ils ne sont pas prêts pour
ce que tu es devenu.
Qu'ils me prennent comme je suis ou
je me passerai du public!
En dix ans, tu as tourné sept
films, gagné deux Grammy Awards,
eu sept titres au top dix de la
chanson,
et été nominé pour les Oscars!
Que veux-tu de plus, bordel?
Je veux juste savoir qui je suis
vraiment, c'est tout.
Le reste du monde a l'air de savoir
qui tu es!
Mais continue à chercher.
Quand tu te seras trouvé
appelle-moi! On verra où on en est!
Tu crois sincèrement que je suis
cinglé?
Ma montre s'est mise à ralentir!
Faudrait la réparer!
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire "ton
temps est écoulé?"
De quoi tu parles?
Mon copain Grégory a dit que mon
temps est écoulé, maintenant.
Ton temps est écoulé? C'est que des
conneries!
Tiens! Tu la porteras
quand tu seras grand.
Je vais devenir grand, tu crois?
Oui, bien sûr! Seulement tu dois y
croire!
Il faut que tu n'arrêtes jamais d'y
croire, Bobby!
Tant que tu y croiras, ce sera le
cas!
Te revoilà! Dis, comment tu te sens?
J'ai l'impression d'avoir comme un
poids sur le coeur.
Ils disent que ça s'est bien passé.
Ils ont remplacé les deux valves.
Ca ne tiendra pas longtemps!
Tu dis ça parce que t'es sous
médocs!
- Il faut que tu manges.
- Que je mange?
Tu n'as pas le droit de manger tout
de suite,
mais je voulais que tu aies quand
même quelques provisions!
- Qu'est-ce que c'est?
- Regarde! De délicieux manicotti!
Et les spaghetti de Nina qui ont
fait tout le voyage depuis New-York
Les spaghetti de Nina?
Mais tu cherches à me tuer?
Tu lui manques tellement, Bobby!
Je vais les appeler, elle et Sandy
et leur dire que tu vas bien. Ok?
Neuf heures sur la table d'opération
et il est toujours en pleine forme!
Vous savez, je parie que le
vieux Docteur Andretti
qui est mort voilà déjà des années,
serait surpris de me voir fêter mon
trente- sixième anniversaire!
Ne piquez pas ça! C'est pas à vous!
- Bon anniversaire!
- Tu es superbe! Bel ensemble!
T'aimes bien? Je l'ai acheté exprès
pour ton anniversaire.
Je voulais que tu voies que ta mère
peut avoir une certaine classe.
Quoi, Bobby?
C'est bon, Nina. Je crois que je
sais pourquoi tu me l'as dit.
Excuse-moi une minute.
- Tu trouves pas qu'il a bonne mine?
- Très bonne mine.
Il a vraiment l'air en pleine forme!
Il finira centenaire, c'est sûr!
- Je t'ai cherché toute la journée!
- Je suis sûre que c'est pas vrai!
- Tu as l'air en forme!
- Je me sens en forme, physiquement.
Je respire enfin correctement pour
la première fois depuis longtemps.
Dodd espère que tu restes un peu à
la maison.
Tu me manques.
Je suis fier de tes efforts Sandy!
- C'est pas facile de résister!
- Je m'en doute.
Ce n'est pas pour ça que tu nous as
quittés! Il y avait plus grave!
Je suis pas celle qui te fallait.
Je suis pas une intellectuelle.
- Je ne suis pas si maligne que toi.
- Tu l'es pour dix gars comme moi!
Et regarde ce que nous avons fait
ensemble!
- Tu vas te remettre à chanter?
- J'adorerais, mais...
Je doute de pouvoir m'habituer à me
faire huer comme ça tous les soirs!
Il ne faut pas leur en vouloir, ils
ne comprennent rien!
T'as toujours eu une longueur
d'avance!
Les gens veulent du spectacle. Ils
ont besoin de voir pour écouter!
Je sais. Qu'est-ce que tu
viens de dire?
- Qu'il ne faut pas leur en vou..
- Non, au sujet des gens qui...quoi?
Fais moi jouer à Las Vegas!
- Tu ne veux pas retourner à Vegas!
- Oh que si!
Je veux retourner à Vegas et je
veux remonter sur scène!
- Ne me dis pas que tu t'es trouvé!
- Non!
- Il veut retourner à Vegas?
- Première nouvelle!
Les night-clubs, c'est ma vie!
J'adore ça!
En plus, je fais ça mieux que
n'importe qui d'autre au monde!
Tu es aussi la personne la plus
modeste de mon entourage
mais je refuse que tu y retournes!
Ca va marcher, cette fois!
Je peux être, dire et chanter
ce que je veux!
Sandy vient de le dire!
Elle l'a dit merveilleusement bien!
Quoi?
Il faut voir pour écouter!
C'est drôle...
Tu n'étais pas une fille qu'un gars
comme moi pouvait espérer épouser!
Je veux dire, je n'étais qu'un
chanteur venu du Bronx...
Toi, tu étais une star de cinéma.
Bobby, qu'est-ce que je vais
devenir, maintenant?
Qu'importe ce que tu deviendras, ma
belle, tu seras toujours Sandra Dee.
- Pourquoi je peux pas l'ouvrir?
- C'est pas un cadeau habituel.
C'est un cadeau très spécial.
Personne ne doit savoir que tu l'as.
Mais qu'est-ce qu'il y a dedans?
Deux millions de dollars en liquide,
mais qui datent de la Confédération
malheureusement!
Non. C'est juste quelques
trucs que je veux te léguer.
Et personne ne doit savoir que je
l'ai? Même pas maman?
Ni maman, ni Charlie, ni tante
Nina... ni grand-mère.
Personne d'autre que toi et moi.
C'est un secret.
Quand est-ce que je pourrai
l'ouvrir?
Quand je ne serai plus là.
J'ai pas envie que tu meures!
Tu sais, je suis pas différent
des autres!
Mon heure viendra peut-être
juste un peu plus tôt, c'est tout!
Et qu'est-ce que je vais devenir?
Toi? Tout ira très bien pour toi!
Si tu es l'homme que je pense que
tu es!
Moi,j'ai dû me battre pour sortir du
Bronx et devenir quelqu'un.
Mais toi, pour sortir de Beverly
Hills,ce sera une autre histoire!
Qu'est-ce que tu fiches là-dedans?
J'essaye de sentir un battement de
coeur!
C'est vraiment pas drôle!
Mon smoking et mon toupet sont
prêts?
Ne t'inquiète pas, tout est prêt!
Ca n'a pas l'air d'aller!
Je suis pas au top, non, pour
te dire la vérité.
Je dois retourner à l'hôpital.
C'est pour ça qu'on repart plus tôt.
J'ai un empoisonnement du sang et
ça attaque mon coeur.
Tu n'es pas obligé de te produire,
on peut annuler!
Il est temps que je m'habille,
Charlie!
Je vais aller vérifier si Nina est
à une bonne table!
Charlie, sans toi je serais jamais
allé aussi loin!
Fiston, t'as toujours été un train
qu'on ne peut pas arrêter!
Roule encore ce soir!
Il faut les quitter quand ils en
demandent encore, Charlie!
Mesdames et Messieurs, je vous
demande d'accueillir chaleureusement
sur la scène du Flamingo le
retour d'un vieil ami
un des plus grands artistes de ce
pays, nominé aux Oscars,
vainqueur par deux fois des Grammy
Awards,
un artiste des plus complets!
Hé! Chante Dream lover!
L'hôtel Flamingo est fier
d'accueillir ce soir
le légendaire... Bobby Darin!
Doux Jésus, Steve! Où t'étais?
- Impossible de sortir de L. A.!
- Faut que tu viennes voir ça!
- Pourquoi? Qu'est-ce qui se passe?
- Tu vas pas le croire! Il a réussi!
"Il faut voir pour écouter"!
Merci. S'il vous plaît,
asseyez-vous. Merci beaucoup!
Merci beaucoup, vous êtes un
merveilleux public!
Et c'est un bonheur d'être de
retour à Las Vegas.
J'espère que vous avez eu de la
chance à vos tables de jeu!
Il est probable que je ne me
produise pas pendant un moment,
j'ai besoin de faire une pause.
C'est pourquoi je ne voudrais pas
rater l'occasion de
faire en public
quelque chose que j'aurai voulu
faire depuis longtemps.
Et c'est de
vous présenter
la femme qui m'a élevé.
Ma mère.
Nina Cassotto Maffia.
Je t'en prie, lève-toi,
maman. Lève-toi!
- C'est mon fils!
- Oui, Nina!
C'est mon fils!
Je voudrais chanter une chanson que
j'ai réécrit exprès pour ce soir.
J'en ai changé les paroles. C'est
une vieille chanson de Bob Hope.
Et nous voulons vous l'interpréter
ce soir en guise de conclusion
et d'au-revoir.
Dès que Richie aura fini de
composer dans son coin!
Ca donne à peu près ceci...
Attends une minute!
Attends une minute! Où tu vas?
- Ben, on a terminé !
- Ne pars pas, ce n'est pas fini!
Voilà l'histoire :
L'homme qu'on croyait être notre
père est en fait notre grand-père.
Le gars qu'on croyait être notre
beau-frère est notre beau-père,
et la femme qu'on croyait notre
soeur
se révèle être notre mère!
Et comme elle a couché avec la
moitié du Bronx,
Dieu seul sait qui était notre père!
Exact. Maintenant qu'on sait tout
ça, on a fini.
Non, pas toi! C'est moi seul qui
vais m'en aller.
Tu n'as pas compris?
Bobby Darin sera toujours là!
- Mais de quoi tu parles?
- Tu ne te souviens pas?
Les souvenirs sont comme des rayons
de lune. On en fait ce qu'on veut!
Ecoute! Ce n'est pas comme ça que
ça finit.
Hé! Garde ceci pour moi!
Traduction Isabelle Legros.
Sous-titres : AGM Factory.